what I agreed to dude is nice ember
brother bear was one of the films I was
looking the least forward to reviewing
okay not the least but we'll get to that
one later I remember seeing the trailers
for than just looking incredibly
uninterested and yeah I guess everybody
else did because the film apparently
didn't do very well
well I sat down I watched it and I have
to say at first I was freaking blown
away by it
the people were likeable and the myths
were likeable all I was saying to myself
was holy smokes this is what Pocahontas
should have been I was getting invested
in these characters I was getting
invested in what happened to them one
character passes away very early on and
you know what I was really sore torn up
about it
the music was nice the animation was
nice I was totally digging it and then
our main character turns into a bear
this is where it all goes down okay let
me clarify I have no problem with the
main character turning into a bear to
learn a lesson in fact I was actually
against it when I heard about it but see
where they were going with everything
else actually pretty excited now they
handled everything else so well I want
to see what they were gonna do with this
what they do with it is about as
predictable and boring and lame as you
can imagine you see the spirit of the
mountain or something like that takes
the body of a young man who's looking
for revenge on a bear and actually turns
him into a bear well he of course wants
to turn back to human and comes across
some colorful characters along the way
one of them is a little cub named Koda
he hangs around him for a bit because
apparently he got separated from his
mother well gee I wonder what happened
to the mother I won't give anything away
but let's just say something happened to
the mother and you'll be really
dumbfounded that throughout this entire
film the main character never figures
out what happened to the mother and
throughout the whole film the bear is
trying to get to the top of the mountain
to figure out how to change himself back
all the while his human brother is
trying to track down and kill the bear
because he wants vengeance too so on a
clip a bit of writing there's no
villain there's just a great big
misunderstanding the brother wants to
kill the bear for a reason we can all
understand he was revenge for his
brother and while of course we see it's
misled we can sense the passion and the
love they had for his brother hence why
he's going to such violent deeds in fact
this whole story turned out to be a
pretty good setup it had a good
beginning and it had a good ending
like I said the middle is where the
problem comes from when the animals have
to talk it's pretty annoying the
language the humans had for the most
part is pretty timeless but here the
animals say stuff like dude and I Spy
and they pinkie swear and do all sorts
of other modern things that people do
and I'm sorry
that's really distracting and on top of
that it doesn't make us connect as well
to the characters what you were doing
before was great we were connecting with
the people because we were connecting
with their culture and their passion and
their beliefs and their myths if I was
driving this never would have happened
here stop let me drive and can't believe
you totaled a mammoth that kind of takes
us out of the magic the kid he has to
look after is really annoying again you
have to be really careful with a little
boy who's trying to act tough because
that can either turn out really annoying
or really charming this is really
annoying surprisingly at first I was
really getting into the music yeah I
thought it was sounding really nice I
saw the Phil Collins was attached to
this and I dreaded it but when I was
hearing that opening music you know what
I was really into it but then
you just couldn't stay out of it could
you Phil okay well maybe he'll just be
like Tarzan where he's kind of annoying
but he's not actually ruining anything I
won't be within my pal
the bear is telling the cub what
happened to the mother and Phil Collins
is singing over it you trusted me
oh fuck you Phil Collins fuck you or
fuck the person who put the song here or
fuck the person who had the idea I put a
song here I write a song about it fuck
somebody this is the worst placement for
a song ever
guys why couldn't you just go with the
musical score here I mean really you
need Phil Collins to come in and sing
it's sad that this pot is sad you're
supposed to cry right now
the bear is sad oh look he's really torn
up I'm not gonna let the scene just play
I'm gonna tell you how to feel oh I'm
Phil Collins I'm fuck you uh so yeah the
obvious plot that anybody can figure out
the modern talk to Phil Collins songs
you'd really think I hate this movie and
well yeah I do really hate parts of it
but damn it those other parts are so
good I mean talk about being so close
and yet so far
well again morally I guess nothing bad
is being said and I guess it could be
worse I mean they don't quote any movies
or anything like that at least not that
I remember but oh it was so close you
almost had this really perfect wonderful
Disney movie and ow Phil Collins modern
talk pinkie swear oh it frustrates me
but on the other hand I guess I really
didn't expect anything to come out of
this movie if they have the good parts
that did come out of it I guess that was
pretty cool
and you know what it is nice to see that
Disney can still get some culture in
their animated films now whether or not
the culture is correct I don't know
because I myself AM on culture but even
if it's not it still makes for
interesting myth and interesting stories
so yeah I love the beginning I love the
ending the middle can suck it
yeah I realize this review is kind of
all over the place but that's really
what I thought when I see it again
probably not but I guess
am glad that I did in fact see it wants
hopefully you can take what I said and
also sort of look at the trailer and see
if this is something that be up your
alley
well either way take a look at and see
for yourself